Alice:收一下
Alice: Clean it up a bit.
Jake: 哎还是给我袋
Jake: Oh, still give me a bag.
Jake: 我还是拿袋子
Jake: I'll still take the bag.
Tasha: 不是说好一起收拾的吗
Tasha: Weren't we supposed to clean up together?
Tasha: 可who在
Alice: 碍事
Alice: In the way.
Jake: 放架子上
Jake: Put it on the shelf.
Jake: 架子上这个帮我挪一下啊
Jake: Help me move this to the shelf.
Tasha: 哇大西不是故意的
Tasha: Wow, Daxi didn't do it on purpose.
Alice: 哇大西不是故意的
Alice: Wow, Daxi didn't do it on purpose.
Tasha: 妈妈桑
Tasha: Mama-san.
Alice: 哈哈妈妈酱妈妈咪呀
Alice: Haha, Mama-chan, Mamma Mia.
Alice: 这个先给他搁冰箱上吧
Alice: Let's put this in the fridge first.
Alice: 我真的想戴上个手套说实话
Alice: Honestly, I really want to wear gloves.
Tasha: 那可以戴那个无菌手套
Tasha: Then you can wear those sterile gloves.
Alice:不还得下去拿
Alice: But I have to go downstairs to get them.
Tasha: 收拾
Tasha: Clean up.
Katrina: 打一套醉拳呐
Katrina: Do a set of drunken boxing.
Katrina: 啊被倒掉了
Katrina: Ah, it got spilled.
Shure:  完了你的斧根被倒掉了
Shure: Oh no, your axe root got spilled.
Shure:  也没有斧了
Shure: And there's no axe.
Katrina:  太好了哇菜刀
Katrina: Great, a kitchen knife!
Shure:  比划两下
Shure: Swing it a bit.
Katrina: 菜刀怎么会出现在这里
Katrina: How did the kitchen knife end up here?
Katrina:  给你舞一个
Katrina: I'll dance with it for you.
Katrina:  自己刀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Dance with the knife, hahaha.
Katrina:  这油倒哪呢
Katrina: Where should I pour this oil?
Tasha: 那
Tasha: Over there.
Shure:  为什么拿他晒
Shure: Why are you sunbathing it?
Shure:  给你倒的酒你没有喝
Shure: The drink I poured for you, you didn't drink it.
Tasha: 我喝了
Tasha: I drank it.
Tasha: 你好会撩哦
Katrina:  倒倒倒哪来的
Katrina: Pour, pour, where did it come from?
Shure:  我来倒吧
Shure: Let me pour it.
Shure:  我来倒我来倒
Shure: I'll pour it, I'll pour it.
Katrina:  倒麻酱里
Katrina: Pour it into the sesame paste.
Tasha: 对先倒到这吧
Tasha: Yes, pour it here first.
Katrina:  小时候我给老鼠做老鼠药就这样
Katrina: When I was a kid, I made rat poison like this.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure:  还做这个呢
Shure: You even made that?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Katrina: 风油精花露水
Katrina: Essential balm and floral water.
Katrina:  加一点好吃的饼干
Katrina: Add some delicious cookies.
Katrina:  哎我看有没有那个塑料袋
Katrina: Hey, let me see if there's a plastic bag.
Katrina:  我们直接扔了
Katrina: Let's just throw it away.
Shure:  你觉得我
Shure: Do you think I...
Shure:  我明天这瓶我觉得就可以喝完了
Shure: I think I can finish this bottle by tomorrow.
Katrina:  哈哈哈再说你你就这样拿
Katrina: Hahaha, and then you just take it like this.
Tasha: 天呐噢
Tasha: Oh my god, oh.
Katrina:  就那天迎宾的时候
Katrina: Just that day when welcoming guests.
Tasha: 老板居然干最辛苦的活
Tasha: The boss actually did the hardest work.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 哎这个盆边好脏
Tasha: Hey, the edge of this basin is so dirty.
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Jake:我去我这个油
Jake: Oh my, this oil.
Jake: 好厚一层
Jake: It's so thick.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Jake:先这么有用你你你来
Jake: Let's try this first, you, you, you come here
Jake: 这厨房水确实挺厉害
Jake: This kitchen water is really something
Shure:  加油加油
Shure: Come on, come on
Jake: 来您您来一起加加油吧
Jake: Come on, you join in too
Jake: 要不
Jake: How about
Jake:来来来来
Jake: Come, come, come
Tasha: 来干活吧
Tasha: Let's get to work
Tasha: 修硕
Tasha: Shure
Tasha: 我教您
Tasha: I'll teach you
Tasha: 您就把这个
Tasha: You just take this
Shure: 我不听加油加油加油我不听
Shure: I'm not listening, come on, come on, come on, I'm not listening
Shure:  加油加油哈哈哈
Shure: Come on, come on, hahaha
Katrina:  你今天晚上任务是负责把
Katrina: Your task tonight is to handle
Katrina:  yes OK
Katrina: Yes, OK
Katrina:  学会明天教我们
Katrina: Learn it and teach us tomorrow
Shure:  我我我今天晚上负负责喝的死死的
Shure: I, I, I am responsible for drinking until I'm dead tonight
Shure:  然后睡觉
Shure: Then sleep
Katrina:  Lucy和儿子太像了呀
Katrina: Lucia looks a lot like her son
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure:  酒精大学四年怎么过来的
Shure: How did I survive college with all that drinking
Katrina:  哎苦学生
Katrina: Ah, poor student
Katrina:  嘘又被我撞到了
Katrina: Shh, you ran into me again
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈嘘
Katrina: Hahaha, shh
Katrina:  大学四年都干什么啊
Katrina: What did you do for four years in college
Katrina:  忘了感觉保研之后才真正大学生活
Katrina: I forgot, it feels like only after getting into grad school did my real college life start
Katrina:  但是我感觉我也没有那种特别
Katrina: But I don't feel like I had that kind of
Katrina:  就是学的特别吓人的那种
Katrina: Like studying really intensely
Katrina:  就是期末周去那种
Katrina: Just during finals week
Katrina:  主要我们班
Katrina: Mainly our class
Katrina:  我们班保研率很高保百分之7
Katrina: Our class had a high rate of grad school admission, about 7%
Katrina:  然后运气特别好
Katrina: Then we were very lucky
Katrina:  然后一般就是我们年级这个实验班
Katrina: Usually, in our grade, the experimental class
Katrina:  他是需要竞争
Katrina: It required competition
Katrina:  大一分流的时候竞争进去
Katrina: Competing to get in during freshman year
Katrina: 我们那一年
Katrina: That year
Katrina:  我们那一年没人报你知道吗
Katrina: That year no one applied, you know
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm
Alice:还有袋没了
Alice: Is there another bag
Katrina:  然后我绩点那么低我都进了
Katrina: And even with my low GPA, I got in.
Tasha: 好像没了
Tasha: Seems like that's it.
Katrina:  然后我就保研了
Katrina: And then I got a guaranteed spot for grad school.
Alice: 这俩是谁的
Alice: Whose are these?
Alice:还喝吗
Alice: Are we still drinking?
Tasha: 好像都不喝了
Tasha: Seems like nobody's drinking anymore.
Alice: 那我倒了
Alice: Then I'll dump it.
Katrina:  我人生很搞笑的我感觉
Katrina: I feel like my life is so funny.
Shure:  东北孩子都会唱刀郎
Shure: Kids from Northeast all know how to sing Daolang.
Katrina: 呀呀呀还有没有
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, any more?
Katrina: 好恶心
Katrina: So gross.
Shure:  你好恶心
Shure: You're so gross.
Katrina:  麻酱no
Katrina: Sesame sauce, no.
Shure:  麻酱no
Shure: Sesame sauce, no.
Katrina: yes no
Katrina: Yes, no.
Shure:  然后醋yes
Shure: Then vinegar, yes.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina:  狂加醋
Katrina: Pour in lots of vinegar.
Jake: 嘿卢亚呢
Jake: Hey, where's Luya?
Shure:  卢亚已经睡着了吧
Shure: Luya's probably asleep.
Shure:  可能
Shure: Maybe.
Katrina:  真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Jake:卢亚带个眼镜呗
Jake: Luya, put on some glasses.
Katrina:  他喝酒了吗
Katrina: Did he drink?
Shure:  他喝了一碗
Shure: He had a bowl.
Jake: 一碗
Jake: A bowl.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: That's it.
Shure:  我们要不晚上再来一局吧
Shure: How about we play another round tonight?
Katrina:  哈哈晚上再来一局
Katrina: Haha, let's play another round tonight.
Katrina:  就直接给你掏心掏肺讲故事了
Katrina: I'll tell you stories straight from the heart.
Shure:  哈哈哈我就要听掏心掏肺讲故事哎
Shure: Haha, I want to hear stories straight from the heart.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure:  其实其实酒桌上掏心掏肺讲故事
Shure: Actually, telling stories straight from the heart at the table.
Shure:  第二天第二另另外几个人都记不住
Shure: The next day, others can't remember.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know that?
Shure:  哈哈哈掏心掏肺讲完了你你很爽
Shure: Haha, after you pour your heart out, you feel great.
Shure:  然后其他人也很爽
Shure: And others feel great too.
Shure:  但是大家都记不住这个事
Shure: But nobody remembers what was said.
Shure:  情就很很很爽
Shure: It just feels really good.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina:  对爽了就行
Katrina: Yeah, as long as it feels good.
Shure:  这大家只走一个过程
Shure: Everyone just goes through it once.
Katrina:  真好呀主要我当时我舍友都特别乖
Katrina: It was nice, especially since my roommates were all so well-behaved.
Katrina:  没人提议说去酒吧
Katrina: No one suggested going to a bar.
Shure:  也不一定非去酒吧呀
Shure: You don’t necessarily have to go to a bar.
Shure:  先喝酒吧
Shure: Just drink first.
Katrina:  他们不喝
Katrina: They don’t drink.
Katrina:  哎呦喝一瓶RIO就倒了
Katrina: Oh man, they’d be out after one bottle of RIO.
Katrina: crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Jake: 这边都不够
Jake: That’s not enough.
Jake: 要不带点下去洗
Jake: How about we take some down to wash?
Jake: 再带一个吧
Jake: Grab another one.
Jake: 碗下去洗吧要不
Jake: Let’s take the bowls down to wash, shall we?
Jake: 这边够了
Jake: That’s enough here.
Shure:  加油加油加油加油加
Shure: Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on!
Katrina: 你跳那个
Katrina: You do that dance.
Alice: 这边这还有
Alice: There’s more over here.
Choiszt: 呃等会你先别扔这个先把这个拿下
Choiszt: Uh, wait, don’t throw that yet, take this down first.
Katrina: cheer up就很元气
Katrina: Cheer up, it’s so energizing.
Katrina:  什么cheerbaby
Katrina: What cheerbaby?
Katrina:  就是他们在干家务的时候
Katrina: It’s like when they’re doing chores,
Katrina:  你就在旁边cheer
Katrina: you just cheer them on.
Katrina:  babycheer
Katrina: Babycheer.
Katrina:  baby
Katrina: Baby.
Shure: 你还会跳
Shure: You can dance too?
Shure:  啊你也会跳这个是吗
Shure: Ah, you can do this dance too?
Katrina:  会啊高中的时候不是可流行的吗
Katrina: Yeah, it was so popular in high school.
Shure:  杨老板会跳这个吗
Shure: Can Jake do this dance?
Shure: 好东西
Shure: Nice stuff.
Jake: 哦会跳这个
Jake: Oh, I can do this dance.
Jake: 因为我我以前我在美国
Jake: Because back when I was in the US,
Jake: 那个房东的小孩
Jake: the landlord’s kid
Jake: 就天天在我面前秀这个
Jake: would show it off in front of me every day.
Tasha: 这个水是用这个是洗不掉的
Tasha: This water won’t wash it off.
Jake: 那用什么
Jake: Then what do we use?
Tasha: 用他抹
Tasha: Use this to wipe it.
Katrina:  也年轻过
Katrina: We were young once too.
Shure:  也年轻过
Shure: We were young once too.
Shure:  谁没年轻过呢是吧
Shure: Who hasn’t been young, right?
Choiszt: 你们这个袋是要扔吗现在
Choiszt: Are you guys going to throw this bag away now?
Tasha: 要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:要扔
Jake: Throw it away.
Choiszt: 带个手套吧
Choiszt: Wear a glove.
Tasha: 哦我还以为你要把它装进来
Tasha: Oh, I thought you were going to pack it up.
Choiszt: 也可以装进来
Choiszt: You can pack it up too.
Jake: 这个碗
Jake: This bowl.
Jake: 有多少是楼下的啊
Jake: How much of this is from downstairs?
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been gone for a while.
Shure:  哲学你懂吗
Shure: Do you understand philosophy?
Shure:  他虽然就是形态站在这
Shure: He might be standing here physically,
Shure:  但是意识已经走了
Shure: But his consciousness has already left.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这还有个男呃好吧他走了
Tasha: There's a guy here, oh well, he's gone.
Katrina:  酒量测试开始
Katrina: Drinking test starts now.
Jake: 这要不放下面洗
Jake: Should we wash this downstairs?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Tasha: 就就在这洗吧
Tasha: Let's just wash it here.
Tasha: 你可以换一张抹布了
Tasha: You can change the rag.
Lucia: 更方便洗一些
Lucia: It's easier to wash that way.
Jake:还还能用
Jake: It can still be used.
Tasha: 这这这
Tasha: This, this, this...
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Tasha: 喝一口啊
Tasha: Take a sip.
Tasha: 这汤好鲜美啊
Tasha: This soup is so delicious!
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 你确实
Tasha: You sure?
Jake: 你说的真的
Jake: If you say it's good,
Jake: 那就是真的
Jake: Then it must be good.
Katrina:  你喝什么呢
Katrina: What are you drinking?
Shure:  你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  哈哈他妈的
Shure: Haha, damn it.
Tasha: 换一张吧
Tasha: Change it.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 我帮你扔掉
Tasha: I'll throw it away for you.
Jake: 谢谢您哎
Jake: Thank you.
Shure:  不是我怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with me?
Tasha: 你看还好买了一包吧
Tasha: Good thing we bought a pack.
Alice: 这个锅原来在二楼吗
Alice: Was this pot originally on the second floor?
Lucia: 这个这个锅吗
Lucia: This pot?
Tasha: 以后不要在家做饭了
Tasha: From now on, let's not cook at home.
Tasha: 没事我说以后不要在家做饭了
Tasha: It's okay, I mean from now on, let's not cook at home.
Jake: 哦为啥
Jake: Oh, why?
Tasha: 洗碗这个活没有人愿意接受
Tasha: No one wants to do the dishes.
Jake: 确实
Jake: True.
Shure:  我觉得
Shure: I think
Shure:  是时候拿出吉他了
Shure: it's time to bring out the guitar.
Alice: 来防一下锅
Alice: Let's cover the pot.
Tasha: 嗯放这吧
Tasha: Hmm, put it here.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 那我把这个也放进去吧
Lucia: Then I'll put this in too.
Tasha: 好像锅也就能放哦锅还没洗
Tasha: Seems like the pot can only fit... Oh, the pot isn't washed yet.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Shure:  洗手间
Shure: The bathroom.
Shure:  帅老师不喜欢回归大自然吗
Shure: Doesn't Mr. Shuai like returning to nature?
Alice: 这谁的呀
Alice: Whose is this?
Tasha: 这个是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Tasha: 但是我没喝完嘛
Tasha: But I haven't finished drinking it.
Alice: 那我给你留这了啊
Alice: Then I'll leave it here for you.
Tasha: 好行
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure:  你喝吗啊
Shure: Are you drinking?
Tasha: 我喝呢
Tasha: I am drinking.
Shure: 你真喝吗
Shure: Are you really drinking?
Tasha: 真喝呢
Tasha: Yes, really drinking.
Tasha: 你喝一杯应该没关系吧
Tasha: You having a glass shouldn't be a problem, right?
Shure:  喝一杯他
Shure: Having a glass...
Shure:  他毫无关系
Shure: It doesn't matter at all.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 醋放下边
Alice: Put the vinegar down there.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 可以竖着放
Tasha: You can put it upright.
Lucia: 啊对不起对不起啊
Lucia: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 刚那个有点使劲好像水崩起来了
Lucia: Just now I pressed too hard, the water splashed.
Lucia: 没有溅到你们身上吧
Lucia: It didn't splash on you, right?
Jake: 好油啊
Jake: So greasy.
Tasha: 没关系这只是洗第一
Tasha: It's okay, this is just the first wash.
Tasha: 遍还有洗第二遍的
Tasha: There's still a second wash.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好油啊
Tasha: So greasy!
Tasha: 你看这个
Tasha: Look at this.
Tasha: 原本是很干净的杯子
Tasha: It was a clean cup.
Tasha: 你把它放到油碗里
Tasha: You put it in the oil bowl.
Tasha: 好油呀他变的呵呵
Tasha: It's so greasy now, haha.
Jake: 擦完就扔洗碗机了一般
Jake: Usually, we just put it in the dishwasher after wiping.
Tasha: 你怎么不购入一台
Tasha: Why don't you get one?
Tasha: 买一个小碗洗碗机吧
Tasha: Buy a small dishwasher.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们有硕
Jake: We have Shure.
Alice: 还有垃圾吗
Alice: Is there any trash left?
Tasha: 硕硕
Tasha: Shure, Shure.
Jake: 来一轮
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: No more.
Alice: 没了
Alice: No more.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个可以当垃圾袋用
Lucia: This can be used as a trash bag.
Lucia: 因为里面扔了很多
Lucia: Because there's a lot inside.
Shure:  what's up bro
Shure: What's up, bro?
Tasha: 让你买个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to buy a dishwasher.
Jake:让你当个洗碗机
Jake: I told you to be the dishwasher.
Tasha: 让你当个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to be the dishwasher.
Shure:  让我买个洗碗机
Shure: Told me to buy a dishwasher.
Jake: 买个是难
Jake: Buying one is hard.
Tasha: 让你当一个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to be the dishwasher.
Shure: 什么买个洗碗机
Shure: What, buy a dishwasher?
Jake: 当个洗碗机
Jake: Be the dishwasher.
Shure:  我靠买个洗碗机
Shure: Damn, buy a dishwasher.
Shure:  真的吗bro
Shure: Really, bro?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: All done.
Tasha: 堵住了你有没有发现需要您清理
Tasha: It's clogged, didn't you notice? You need to clean it.
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha: 这筷子洗的
Tasha: These chopsticks are washed.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 真有水平
Tasha: Really well done.
Shure:  跟洗跟没洗的一样
Shure: Looks like they weren't washed at all.
小薇 ：你看他这个筷子洗的
Tasha: Look at his chopsticks.
Tasha: 洗成两坨了
Tasha: They turned into two lumps.
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake: 跟没洗的一样
Jake: It's like it wasn't washed at all.
Tasha: 我真受不了了
Tasha: I really can't stand it.
Shure:  一看就是在家
Shure: You can tell it was done at home.
Shure:  一天天娇生惯养的孩子们
Shure: Spoiled kids every single day.
Jake: 可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, give me a break.
Jake: 谁在家呢
Jake: Who's at home?
Shure:  请问在在Singapore
Shure: Excuse me, in Singapore.
Shure:  娇生惯养的孩子
Shure: Spoiled kids.
Jake: 那也没在在Singapore也不在家待着
Jake: Even in Singapore, they don't just stay at home.
Shure:  哎我搅一会吧
Shure: Let me stir it for a bit.
Shure:  然后先让他水流下去
Shure: Then let the water flow down first.
Jake:我这先搁哪呢
Jake: Where should I put this first?
Shure:  你随便搁哪都行
Shure: You can put it anywhere.
Shure:  然后我搅一会就行
Shure: I'll stir it for a bit, and it's done.
Shure:  你别搁搁地漏上就行
Shure: Just don't put it on the drain.
Jake: 我先去洗洗手去
Jake: I'll go wash my hands first.
Shure:  哎愁死了
Shure: This is so frustrating.
Tasha: 这油的
Tasha: It's so greasy.
Tasha: 哈哈哈洗碗机成功
Tasha: Haha, the dishwasher worked!
Shure:  ai看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
Shure:  就是人类搅一圈之后
Shure: After a human stirs it once,
Shure:  手上会有这么多油
Shure: there's so much grease on their hands.
Shure:  你记住了吗
Shure: Did you remember that?
Lucia: 你记住了吗
Lucia: Did you remember that?
Shure:  侮辱杨老板的数据石吧
Shure: Insulting Jake's data stone.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 这越洗越油
Tasha: The more you wash, the greasier it gets.
Tasha: 不要用另一只手摸他了
Tasha: Don't touch it with your other hand.
Tasha: 你拿那个湿巾擦一擦
Tasha: Use a wet wipe to clean it.
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Alice: 这洗好了吗
Alice: Is this clean now?
Tasha: 这还要再冲一遍呢
Tasha: It needs to be rinsed again.
Tasha: 这只用洗洁精抹了一遍
Tasha: It's only been wiped with dish soap once.
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 你经常干这个活啊
Tasha: Do you do this often?
Tasha: 把里面的渣渣能不能捞出来
Tasha: Can you scoop out the bits inside?
Tasha: 倒也不用这么干净吧我觉得
Tasha: It doesn't have to be that clean, I think.
Shure:  咱过四五天呢哥
Shure: What about four or five days, brother?
Tasha: 要不以后别用楼上的厨房了
Tasha: Maybe we shouldn't use the upstairs kitchen anymore.
Shure: 要不以后别用厨房了都点外卖
Shure: How about we stop using the kitchen and just order takeout from now on?
Shure: 咱买一次性的锅
Shure: Let's buy disposable pots.
Tasha:还有一次性的锅这种说法
Tasha: There's even such a thing as disposable pots?
Shure:  有那锡纸锅两块钱一个哈哈
Shure: Yeah, those foil pots, two bucks each, haha.
Tasha: 你就是专业干这个的呀
Tasha: You're really a pro at this, huh?
Tasha: 怪不得喊你来当洗碗机呢
Tasha: No wonder they asked you to be the dishwasher.
Lucia: 这边我觉得还是
Lucia: I think over here...
Tasha: 需要帮忙吗
Tasha: Do you need help?
Lucia: 这太高了吧
Lucia: This is too high.
Lucia: 放下来一点
Lucia: Lower it a bit.
Tasha: 这个还要再冲一遍了
Tasha: This needs to be rinsed again.
Alice: 你手串是开过光的吗
Alice: Is your bracelet blessed?
Alice: 你那手串开过光吗
Shure:  没有女朋友随便送我的
Shure: No, my girlfriend casually gave it to me.
Tasha: 肯定是他不要的哈哈哈
Tasha: She definitely didn't want it, haha.
Shure:  我就你会说话是不是
Shure: You always have something to say, huh?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  你信不信我这这盘子抡你脑袋上
Shure: Do you believe I'll smack you with this plate?
Tasha: 你说随便送东西的
Tasha: You said she gave it casually.
Tasha: 肯定是她淘汰下来的货
Tasha: It must be something she didn't want.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  因为我平时平时穿粉色衣服多
Shure: Because I usually wear pink clothes.
Shure:  然后送我一个粉色手串
Shure: So she gave me a pink bracelet.
Tasha: 哦你早说嘛
Tasha: Oh, you should've said so earlier.
Tasha: 是她特地送给你的不就行了
Tasha: She specifically gave it to you, that's fine.
Tasha: 你为什么说是随便送给你的
Tasha: Why did you say she gave it casually?
Alice: 要轻描淡写过去这个话题哈哈哈
Alice: Just brush over this topic lightly, haha.
Tasha: 然后还说要打我
Tasha: And then you say you'll hit me.
Alice: 哎我手机好像
Alice: Oh, my phone...
Shure:  把杯子先都刷出来了
Shure: Let's wash all the cups first.
Shure:  因为杯子啊
Shure: Because cups...
Shure:  啊对于喝酒
Shure: Are really important for drinking, so wash them all.
Shure:  来说很重要所以要都刷出来
Shure: So we need to wash them all.
Shure:  这本来就有杯子
Shure: We originally had cups.
Shure:  咱们都使完了你知道吗
Shure: We used them all up, you know?
Lucia: 不是我是说
Lucia: No, I mean...
Lucia: 就是我没看到有刷完需要擦的杯子
Lucia: I didn't see any cups that needed drying.
Lucia: 就是你这不是正刷着吗
Lucia: You're still washing them, right?
Shure:  行了我刷了我刷了
Shure: Alright, I'm washing, I'm washing.
Shure:  哎呦呦呦呦
Shure: Oh my, oh my.
Shure:  帮我拿点谢谢
Shure: Help me grab some, thanks.
Shure:  愁死了
Shure: This is so frustrating.
Shure:  什什么喝完酒还要刷杯子呀
Shure: What? We have to wash glasses after drinking?
Shure:  卧槽这是
Shure: Oh my god, this is...
Alice: 啊这还有俩锅
Alice: Oh, there are still two pots left.
Shure:  杨老板给我结double工资
Shure: Jake, give me double pay.
Shure:  不然话我不干了杨老板
Shure: Otherwise, I quit, Jake.
Tasha: 这可不是你能决定的
Tasha: That's not up to you to decide.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我把这碗拿下拿到楼下刷一下算了
Lucia: I'll take this bowl downstairs to wash it.
Shure:  这碗不是刷完的吗
Shure: Didn't we already wash that bowl?
Lucia: 不是要再涮一遍吗
Lucia: Don't we need to wash it again?
Tasha: 再冲一遍就行了
Tasha: Just rinse it again.
Shure: 你哎
Shure: You, hey...
Tasha: 拿下去
Tasha: Take it down.
Shure:  哎再再给我用一下
Shure: Hey, use it again for me.
Tasha: 旁边还有洗洁精呢
Tasha: There's detergent next to you.
Shure:  不要了
Shure: Never mind.
Alice: 有点难受了
Alice: I'm feeling a bit uncomfortable.
Alice: 热热的
Alice: It's so hot.
Tasha: 不知道明天干嘛
Tasha: I don't know what to do tomorrow.
Katrina:  明天干嘛
Katrina: What to do tomorrow?
Katrina:  我要写小本了
Katrina: I need to write my journal.
Alice: 明天搓麻将
Alice: Let's play mahjong tomorrow.
Alice: 我能不能看着搓啊
Alice: Can I watch you play?
Tasha: 看着搓什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean by watching?
Alice:就看着别人打
Alice: Just watch others play.
Tasha: 也可以呢
Tasha: That's fine too.
Tasha: 人够的话
Tasha: If there are enough people.
Alice:四个人很简单的吧
Alice: Four people should be easy, right?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: I guess.
Tasha: 不知道谁打呢
Tasha: Not sure who's playing.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  现在是期中考试月
Katrina: It's midterm exam month.
Shure:  你们还有期中考试吗
Shure: You still have midterms?
Katrina:  没有看我学弟他们发的朋友圈
Katrina: No, I saw my juniors posting about it on social media.
Katrina:  他们在痛苦我在快乐
Katrina: They're suffering while I'm happy.
Shure:  都多大了还还期中考试呢
Shure: You're that old and still have midterms?
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝宝
Katrina: I'm a good student who loves learning.
Shure:  你是一个爱学习的人
Shure: You're a person who loves learning.
Katrina:  哈哈哈气死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm so mad.
Shure:  我是一个爱学习的人
Shure: I'm someone who loves to study.
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝
Katrina: I'm a good kid who loves to study.
Katrina:  整点music
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Shure:  什么什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: When are you going to clean the room?
Shure:  快扫房间
Shure: Hurry up and clean the room.
Shure:  然后把这个眼镜摘了
Shure: And take off these glasses.
Alice: 嗯这
Alice: Hmm, this...
Alice: 需要
Alice: I need...
Katrina:  你去跟老板介绍一下
Katrina: Go introduce yourself to the boss.
Katrina:  吹一下
Katrina: Blow him away.
Katrina:  听过这个卢广冢的歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard of Lu Guangzhong's songs?
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina:  卢广冢
Katrina: Lu Guangzhong.
Shure:  听过
Shure: Yeah, I've heard.
Katrina:  哎哎我这平板那个音效特好
Katrina: Hey, the sound quality on my tablet is great.
Katrina:  4个
Katrina: Four speakers.
Katrina: 买来听歌
Katrina: Bought it just to listen to music.
Katrina:  学习一点没干
Katrina: Haven't done any studying.
Lucia: 啥意思这从
Lucia: What does that mean, from...
Lucia: 哦这从有抹布
Lucia: Oh, there's a cloth.
Katrina:  我靠跟音响一样
Katrina: Wow, it sounds just like a speaker.
Shure:  走去楼下听去
Shure: Let's go downstairs and listen.
Katrina:  楼下咋了
Katrina: What's up with downstairs?
Katrina:  PK一下你的音响跟我的平板吗
Katrina: Do you want to compare your speakers with my tablet?
Shure:  开玩笑那两个独立单元跟你这个比
Shure: Are you kidding? Those two units compared to this?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我这一个这一个
Katrina: Hahaha, I have this one and this one.
Shure:  喝点嘛喝点嘛
Shure: Have a drink, come on.
Katrina:  又想套我话是不是哈哈哈
Katrina: You want to get me talking, don't you? Hahaha.
Shure:  喝点喝点来来来
Shure: Have a drink, come on, come on.
Katrina: 不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  今天晚上还有东西要干呢
Katrina: I still have stuff to do tonight.
Shure:  我24号交毕设
Shure: I have to submit my graduation project on the 24th.
Shure:  你几号交毕设
Shure: When do you have to submit yours?
Katrina:  你论文写完了吗
Katrina: Have you finished your thesis?
Shure:  写差不多了
Shure: Almost done.
Katrina:  呀怎么切了呀给我
Katrina: Oh no, why did it stop? Give it to me.
Katrina:  这什么老歌
Katrina: What is this old song?
Katrina:  林志炫的
Katrina: It's by Terry Lin.
Katrina:  我要去把楼下那个to do list写一下
Katrina: I need to go downstairs and write that to-do list.
Shure:  to do list是吗
Shure: Is it the to-do list?
Katrina:  明天
Katrina: Tomorrow.
Lucia: 我靠嘞
Lucia: Oh my god.
Katrina:  成为一个自带BGM的女生
Katrina: To become a girl with her own BGM.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  明天干什么呀
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Shure:  杨老板我们什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: Jake, when are we cleaning the room?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Lucia: 你说咱还有
Lucia: You think we still have...
Alice:这个刷了吗
Alice: Did you wash this?
Lucia: 呃我不知道
Lucia: Uh, I don't know.
Lucia: 因为我只刷了第二遍的那个碗
Lucia: Because I only washed that bowl the second time.
Lucia: 这个我也不清楚不清楚是谁洗的这个也要
Lucia: I'm not sure who washed this. This needs to be...
Lucia: 再弄一遍
Lucia: Washed again.
Lucia: 要不把它再
Lucia: Or just...
Lucia: 擦就算了你看这
Lucia: Wipe it off. Look at this...
Lucia: 都没那啥
Lucia: It's not even...
Alice:我们现在没有
Alice: We don't have...
Alice: 我现在没有
Alice: I don't have...
Alice: 我们现在没有那个洗洁精了这会
Alice: We don't have any dish soap right now.
Lucia: 拿下去了是吗
Lucia: You took it, right?
Alice: 对所以就这样吧
Alice: Yeah, so let's just leave it.
Lucia: 这是啥这是油污净
Lucia: What's this? Is this grease cleaner?
Lucia: 这是不是可以用来洗那个啥
Lucia: Can this be used to wash that?
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is...
Lucia: 洗这个池子
Lucia: To clean the sink.
Alice: 清洁除胶
Alice: Adhesive remover.
Alice: 这个是可以弄这个的
Alice: This can be used for this.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 洗池子碗应该不行
Lucia: To clean the sink, but not for bowls.
Lucia: 这个碗看起来也不怎么干净
Lucia: This bowl doesn't look very clean either.
Alice: 今天几点结束呢
Alice: When do we finish today?
Tasha: 好像说很快
Tasha: It seems soon.
Tasha: 等录完房间就结束了
Tasha: Once we finish recording the room.
Alice: 不还要交换礼物吗
Alice: Don't we still need to exchange gifts?
Tasha: 哦对哦
Tasha: Oh, right.
Tasha: 歇会吧
Tasha: Let's take a break.
Tasha: 他们都开始在楼下唱歌了
Tasha: They're already singing downstairs.
Alice: 但是这剩下来的那个什么还没清洁呢
Alice: But the rest of this stuff hasn't been cleaned yet.
Lucia: 我在想这个锅
Lucia: I'm thinking about this pot.
Lucia: 这锅看起来太大了
Lucia: This pot looks too big.
Lucia: 怎么都放不到那里边这怎么
Lucia: How can it not fit in there?
Alice:洗洁精是不是也下去了
Alice: Did the dish soap go in too?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:怎么说这锅原来在哪来着
Alice: By the way, where was this pot originally?
Tasha: 就可以放这
Tasha: It can be placed here.
Tasha: 在下面但是也可以放上面
Tasha: Down below or up above.
Tasha: 放哪都行其实
Tasha: Actually, anywhere is fine.
Tasha: 这是真唱吗
Tasha: Is this live singing?
Alice: 不知道听不出来
Alice: I don't know, can't tell.
Alice: ：表达很快乐
Alice: It sounds very happy.
Lucia: 我们接下来要干嘛呀
Lucia: What are we going to do next?
Tasha: 那就在楼上躺一会吧
Tasha: Let's just lie down upstairs for a bit.
Tasha: 哈哈在楼上摸鱼
Tasha: Haha, just goof around upstairs.
Tasha: 先摸会鱼吧
Tasha: Let's goof around first.
Tasha: 他女朋友送他手串怎么不带了
Tasha: Why isn't he wearing the bracelet his girlfriend gave him?
Alice:是他女朋友送的吗
Alice: Did his girlfriend give it to him?
小薇 ：他刚不
Tasha: Didn't he just...
Lucia: 他刚不是说女朋友
Lucia: Didn't he just say his girlfriend...
Tasha: 对啊啊
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 啊女朋友吗
Alice: Oh, his girlfriend?
Lucia: 那可能就是这个对话发生的时候
Lucia: Maybe when that conversation happened...
Lucia: 你不在
Lucia: You weren't there.
Lucia: 你可能没听到
Lucia: You probably didn't hear it.
Alice: 我就听见一个女生朋友随便送的
Alice: I just heard it was a friend who gave it casually.
Alice:交换礼物是抽吗我会抽到谁呢
Alice: Is the gift exchange a draw? Who will I draw?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Alice:小礼物
Alice: Small gifts.
Lucia: 我发现快递到咱们这还挺慢的我现在在想
Lucia: I noticed that the delivery here is quite slow. Now I'm wondering...
Lucia: 我东西现在下单还能不能到
Lucia: If I order things now, will they still arrive?
Lucia: 因为我有好些还没还没那什么
Lucia: Because I still have a lot of... haven't...
Alice: 我们都还没有买
Alice: We haven't bought anything yet.
Lucia: 我光挑了对我今天光挑了一下
Lucia: I was just picking... I just picked some today.
Lucia: 加了好些购物车但是都没有那个啥
Lucia: Added a lot to the cart but didn't complete it.
Alice: 明天是不是要录麻将
Alice: Are we recording mahjong tomorrow?
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha: 感觉每天都会说
Tasha: Feels like we say it every day.
Tasha: 但是每天都不执行
Tasha: But never actually do it.
Tasha: 因为感觉大家都很难启动的样子
Tasha: Because it seems like everyone has a hard time getting started.
Lucia: 大家都是p人
Lucia: Everyone's just being lazy.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 我昨天本来想着口红今天就要讨论
Lucia: I was planning to discuss the lipstick today
Lucia: 出大概装修成什么样
Lucia: And how the renovation should look
Lucia: 然后今天就要开始下单了
Lucia: Then I was going to place the orders today
Lucia: 但今天好像也没有讨
Lucia: But we haven't even discussed
Lucia: 就是具体的讨论我也没发
Lucia: The specifics yet
Alice:今天周三了是吗四五六
Alice: It's Wednesday today, right? Thursday, Friday, Saturday
Alice:四五六周日不就happy了
Alice: Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday will be happy
Alice: 嗯周周一啊
Alice: Hmm, then Monday
Alice: 这这几天挺快的
Alice: These past few days have gone by fast
Alice: 好烫好难受
Alice: It's so hot, it's uncomfortable
Lucia: 所以他如果周日才到的话就很紧张
Lucia: So if he arrives on Sunday, it'll be tight
Lucia: 必须要周六的时候到
Lucia: He must arrive on Saturday
Lucia: 但是今天已经17号了明天181920
Lucia: But today is already the 17th, tomorrow is the 18th, 19th, 20th
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello
Lucia: 哈喽
Lucia: Hello
Alice: 还有两个锅
Alice: There are two pots left
Tasha: 就只剩两个锅了
Tasha: Only two pots left
Alice: 还有一个池子
Alice: And one sink
Jake: 还有一个池子
Jake: And one sink
Tasha: 也已经挺干净的了
Tasha: It's already pretty clean
Lucia: 池子
Lucia: The sink
Jake: 还是
Jake: Still
Alice:池子用这个就行了
Alice: The sink can be cleaned with this
Lucia: 池子可以用油污净
Lucia: The sink can be cleaned with degreaser
Lucia: 但是我但是我在想那个锅
Lucia: But I'm thinking about the pot
Lucia: 因为那锅好像放不进来
Lucia: Because it doesn't seem to fit
Jake:哦就是准备泡一泡是吧还是啥
Jake: Oh, so are you planning to soak it or what?
Alice: 这个就全是清洁吗
Alice: Is this all for cleaning?
Jake: 那锅能擦干净吗
Jake: Can that pot be cleaned?
Lucia: 这个应该不能洗锅这只能洗
Lucia: This can't be used for pots, only for...
Alice:这个只能用来擦厨房表面
Alice: This can only be used to wipe kitchen surfaces
Lucia: 现在现在洗洁精好像在楼下是吧
Lucia: The dish soap is downstairs, right?
Alice: 他为什么连个喷头都没有啊
Alice: Why doesn't it even have a spray nozzle?
Lucia: 感觉非常的宽
Lucia: It feels really wide
Lucia: 看是
Lucia: Look, it's...
Alice:擦应该擦不干净
Alice: Wiping it probably won't clean it well
Lucia: 当然也可以勉强这样子一下
Lucia: But we can still manage it somehow
Lucia: 就就是他对不太准
Lucia: It’s just not very accurate
Lucia: 那个什么
Lucia: That thing...
Lucia: 擦咱能把它擦明白吗
Lucia: Can we clean this up properly?
Jake:试试
Jake: Let's try.
Alice:洗洁精在下面
Alice: The detergent is down there.
Lucia: 把它擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it a bit.
Lucia: 然后直接用水冲冲就完事了
Lucia: Then just rinse it with water, and that's it.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 可以吗
Lucia: Is that okay?
Alice: 这个都洗好了
Alice: This is all washed now.
Lucia: 我觉得好像也能擦个七七八八的
Lucia: I think we can almost clean it up.
Lucia: 就是有点费纸
Lucia: It just uses a lot of paper.
Lucia: 我们是不是不应该说那个F2word
Lucia: Shouldn't we avoid saying that F word?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia: 哈哈哈没有没有
Lucia: Haha, nothing, nothing.
Lucia: 我刚才感叹了一句
Lucia: I just exclaimed.
Lucia: 那个f word
Lucia: That F word.
Lucia: 我们是不是不能说那个fword
Lucia: Shouldn't we avoid saying that F word?
Lucia: 会被和谐
Lucia: It might get censored.
Tasha: 和谐就和谐
Tasha: Let it be censored then.
Lucia: 自带一声哔
Lucia: It comes with a beep sound.
Lucia: 那电影里面出现fword的时候都会
Lucia: In movies, when the F word appears, it's always
Lucia: 消音
Lucia: muted.
Tasha: 消音
Tasha: Muted.
Lucia: 这真的很勉强
Lucia: This is really tough.
Alice:我觉得还是得用洗洁精
Alice: I think we still need to use detergent.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Alice: 你把它拿上来
Alice: Bring it up here.
Lucia: 也行啊
Lucia: Sure.
Alice: 还要把他拿下去
Alice: And then take it down again.
Lucia: 还是拿洗洁精算了这锅什么的这么大咱要把两个搬下去吗
Lucia: Better use detergent. The pot is so big, should we carry both down?
Alice:那我下去拿吧
Alice: I'll go down and get it then.
Lucia: 这个要纯粹用这个还是
Lucia: Should we use this entirely or...
Alice:你的无菌手套在哪
Alice: Where are your sterile gloves?
Tasha: 在那个冰箱上
Tasha: On the fridge.
Jake: 擦完了
Jake: All done.
Lucia: 没有这个要纯粹用它擦干净太难擦了
Lucia: No, using this alone to clean is too tough.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我把那边那个
Lucia: I used that one over there.
Lucia: 这大概花了三四张纸然后擦出来的
Lucia: It took about three or four sheets of paper to clean.
Lucia: 虽然比刚开始干净多了
Lucia: It's much cleaner than before,
Lucia: 但是没有那个啥那么干净
Lucia: but not as clean as it should be.
Jake: 我现在要扫一遍房间
Jake: I'm going to sweep the room now.
Jake: 但是可能也不是现在
Jake: But maybe not right now.
Jake: 我在想什么时候扫比较方便
Jake: I'm thinking about when it would be convenient to sweep.
Lucia: 我已经收拾的差不多了
Lucia: I've pretty much tidied up already.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: OK行
Jake: OK, sure.
Tasha: 然后我们要干嘛
Tasha: So, what should we do next?
Jake: 你们在下面聊聊
Jake: You guys can chat downstairs.
Jake: 礼物你们怎么互送抓阄还是
Jake: How are you going to exchange gifts? Draw lots or...?
Lucia: 我都可以我是一个什么都可以的p人
Lucia: I'm fine with anything, I'm pretty easygoing.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Tasha: 我想不到好的办法
Tasha: I can't think of a good way.
Lucia: 大家有什么idea吗哈哈
Lucia: Does anyone have any ideas? Haha.
Jake: 摇骰子吧
Jake: Let's roll dice.
Tasha: 谁大谁先挑
Tasha: Whoever gets the highest goes first.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Alice:挑啥呀
Alice: What are we choosing?
Tasha: 挑礼物摇骰子
Tasha: Choosing gifts by rolling dice.
Alice:挑礼物
Alice: Choosing gifts.
Lucia: 鉴于我的礼物是个小choker
Lucia: Since my gift is a little choker,
Lucia: 所以我认为男生如果抽到的话
Lucia: if a guy gets it,
Lucia: 并没有什么
Lucia: it doesn't really...
Tasha: choker
Tasha: A choker?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 这怎么是烂的
Alice: How is this broken?
Jake: 这样吧你们下去聊聊明天的计划
Jake: How about you guys go downstairs and talk about tomorrow's plans?
Tasha: 明天干嘛
Tasha: What's happening tomorrow?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow's outdoor activities.
Tasha: 户外
Tasha: Outdoor activities?
Jake: 采采风
Jake: Taking in the scenery.
Tasha: 采什么风
Tasha: Taking in what scenery?
Jake: 拍拍照片
Jake: Taking photos.
Jake: 玩一玩
Jake: Having fun.
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Like that?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 游客照吗
Lucia: Tourist photos?
Tasha: 野餐吗
Tasha: A picnic?
Jake: 呃最后一天可能放点短片什么的
Jake: Uh, we might show some short clips on the last day.
Jake: 其实
Jake: Actually...
Jake: 原来想要有一个剧本结果好像也没有
Jake: Originally, I wanted to have a script, but it seems like we don't have one.
Jake: 什么剧本
Jake: What script?
Lucia: 不是您不是有个剧本吗
Lucia: Didn't you have a script?
Tasha: 您不是有个备用剧本吗
Tasha: Didn't you have a backup script?
Tasha: 那要不我们现在找一个剧本
Tasha: How about we find a script now?
Tasha: 然后我们开演吧
Tasha: And then we can start performing.
Tasha:只需要本性出演即可
Tasha: Just act naturally.
Lucia: 你知道韩国有一个
Lucia: You know, in Korea, there's a
Lucia: 就是类似于哔哩哔哩上面那种小
Lucia: There's a team that does short films, like on Bilibili.
Lucia: 短片的那么一个团队
Lucia: They are like
Lucia: 他们是就是
Lucia: Since we've been discussing MBTI stuff lately,
Lucia: 既然我们最近几天
Lucia: They've been
Lucia: 一直在讨论MBTI的事情
Lucia: They've been making these MBTI short skits.
Lucia: 就他们是就是就是一直在做一些就是
Lucia: So, they make these little MBTI scenarios.
Lucia: 呃通
Lucia: Um, like
Lucia: 就是这种MBTI的这种小情景短剧
Lucia: These small MBTI situational skits.
Tasha: 小什么
Tasha: Small what?
Lucia: 就是情景短剧
Lucia: 就是比如说比如说你是假设你是你是
Lucia: For example, let's say you're a J type
Lucia: 你是j人
Lucia: And I'm a P type.
Lucia: 然后我是p人
Lucia: And we're discussing a topic.
Lucia: 然后我们俩比如说在讨论某个问题
Lucia: So, like, J types probably have certain views,
Lucia: 然后就是j人可能就是呃呃
Lucia: And P types probably have different views.
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: J types usually think like this,
Lucia: 然后p人
Lucia: And P types
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: Usually think like that.
Lucia: 对就是但是他是以一种就是
Lucia: But it's not rigid or academic,
Lucia: 不是那么很刻板和学术
Lucia: It has a context.
Lucia: 他确实会有一个语境
Lucia: Like, for example,
Lucia: 比如说啊
Lucia: If
Lucia: 我们三个围在一起吃火锅啊什么的
Lucia: The three of us are having hotpot together,
Lucia: 然后突然聊到什么问题
Lucia: And we suddenly discuss something.
Lucia: 然后比如说就是
Lucia: For example,
Lucia: 就是因为
Lucia: Like,
Lucia: 比如说那个今天的月亮好圆啊
Lucia: Today's moon is so round.
Lucia: 不是表白的时候经常用的一句话吗
Lucia: It's a common phrase for confessions, right?
Lucia: 或者什么
Lucia: Or like,
Lucia: 我想跟你看今天的月亮怎么怎么样
Lucia: I want to watch the moon with you.
Lucia: 然后就是如果是t人的话
Lucia: And if it's a T type,
Lucia: 就会觉得啊
Lucia: They would think, ah
Lucia: 为什么要说这句话
Lucia: Why would you say that?
Lucia: 然后如果是f人的话
Lucia: And if it's for girls
Lucia: 就会很快get到
Lucia: They would get it quickly
Lucia: 然后觉得啊好浪漫什么的这种
Lucia: And think, "Oh, how romantic," that kind of thing
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Tasha: 那就是按聊天
Tasha: So, just chat
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Lucia: 就是如果有
Lucia: Like, if there's
Lucia: 比如说有类似的这样的剧本的话
Lucia: For example, a script like this
Lucia: 我们可以按照他随便演一下
Lucia: We can just improvise a bit
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Just
Lucia: 如果我们实在找不到什么别的XTV剧
Lucia: If we really can't find any other XTV shows
Jake: OK其实也不用我
Jake: OK, actually we don't need me
Jake: 我就觉得就是
Jake: I just think
Jake: 可能就是最后一天放点背景墙
Jake: Maybe on the last day, we put up some background walls
Jake: 上面放点照片得了
Jake: Put some photos on them
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too
Tasha: 我以为是要演电视剧
Tasha: I thought we were going to act in a TV series
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 就是这种有剧情的短片
Jake: Like a short film with a plot
Jake: 如果有的话就可以
Jake: If we have one, we can do it
Jake: 其实就是世界地球日
Jake: Actually, it's Earth Day
Jake: 可能这个迎接的时候可能放点PPT
Jake: Maybe during the celebration we can show some PPTs
Jake: 放点电影
Jake: Show some movies
Jake: 放点短片这种
Jake: Show some short films
Jake: 然后明天可能就在户外玩一玩
Jake: And then tomorrow we can play outdoors
Jake: 拍一拍拉倒了对
Jake: Take some photos, and that's it
Lucia: 是想拍一个vlog之类的吗
Lucia: Do you want to shoot a vlog or something?
Jake: 可以是
Jake: We could
Jake: 那要不每人拍个vlog得了
Jake: How about everyone shoots a vlog?
Jake: 其实就是拍点户外的素材
Jake: Just shoot some outdoor footage
Jake: 你们在户外
Jake: You guys outdoors
Jake: 可能也会有一些奇怪的activity
Jake: There might be some weird activities
Jake: 就是
Jake: Like
Tasha: 行为
Tasha: Actions
Jake: 就不是室内的activity吧
Jake: Just not indoor activities
Jake: 就是可能在河边走走啊
Jake: Like maybe walking by the river
Jake: 就就是做点素材吧
Jake: Just to get some footage
Jake: 就是就我也不知道干什么
Jake: I don't really know what else
Jake: 就是多拍照
Jake: Just take more photos
Jake: 然后最后能放到最后一天就行
Jake: Then, we can save it for the last day.
Jake: 在最后一天能够呈现
Jake: Present it on the last day.
Jake: 然后能演到今天就行
Jake: And if we can perform it today, that’s fine.
Lucia: 所以我们最后一天到底需要有一个
Lucia: So, do we need to have a script for the last day?
Lucia: 不是您指的这个剧本是什么意思
Lucia: Or what do you mean by the script you mentioned?
Lucia: 是我们这些天的活动的一个一个剧本
Lucia: Is it like a script for each day's activities?
Lucia: 然后在最后一天呈现吗
Lucia: And then present it on the last day?
Lucia: 只不过现在把这个idea pass掉了
Lucia: But now we're passing on this idea.
Tasha: 他没有任何的剧本
Tasha: He doesn't have any script.
Jake: 对没有任何的剧本
Jake: Yes, there's no script.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 不是我一般以为team Lidar都是一个j
Lucia: I thought team Lidar always had a script.
Jake: 哈哈哈因为这个就很火
Jake: Hahaha, because this is very popular.
Jake: 本身就是一个
Jake: It's basically a...
Jake: 叫什么生活类数据集
Jake: What do you call it, a lifestyle dataset.
Jake: 对爱干啥都行
Jake: Yeah, you can do whatever you want.
Jake: 最后只要能联系上就行
Jake: As long as you can connect in the end.
Tasha: 爱睡觉行吗
Tasha: Is sleeping okay?
Jake: 就得动起来
Jake: You have to be active.
Tasha: 哦爱打游戏行吗
Tasha: Oh, is playing games okay?
Jake: 那你得一边
Jake: Then you have to...
Jake: 你得跳着舞打
Jake: Dance while playing.
Lucia: 健身环哈哈哈
Lucia: Fitness Ring, hahaha.
Tasha: 健身房里面玩金铲铲啊
Tasha: Playing mobile games in the gym?
Lucia: 没有我说的是switch那个健身环
Lucia: No, I mean the Fitness Ring on Switch.
Lucia: 哦不过健身房里玩也可以啊
Lucia: Oh, but playing in the gym is okay too.
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 跑步机哈哈哈
Lucia: On a treadmill, hahaha.
Jake: 对明天就
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow...
Tasha: researcher
Tasha: Researcher.
Tasha: 在这里哈哈
Tasha: Here, haha.
Jake: 嗯好research
Jake: Yeah, alright, research.
Jake: OK research
Jake: OK, research.
Lucia: 我们有个地点吗
Lucia: Do we have a location?
Lucia: 周围有啥
Lucia: What's around?
Jake:对有个公园
Jake: Yeah, there's a park.
Lucia: 公园
Lucia: A park?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 有多大呀能玩一天吗哈哈哈
Lucia: How big is it? Can we play there all day? Hahaha.
Lucia: 我想了想户外
Lucia: I was thinking about outdoor...
Lucia: hiking
Tasha: hiking
Tasha: 会被晒黑吧
Tasha: We might get tanned.
Tasha: 就喜欢公园能玩一天吗
Tasha: Do you like parks enough to play all day?
Lucia: 我觉得这这么小的
Lucia: I think it's such a small
Lucia: 村子应该
Lucia: village, it should
Lucia: 公园不是很大
Lucia: The park isn't very big.
Lucia: 所以我们可以在公园里面再来一次
Lucia: So we can play another
Lucia: 破冰游戏
Lucia: icebreaker game in the park.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:也可以啊
Jake: Sure, we can do that.
Tasha: 既然大家都是研究生了
Tasha: Since everyone is a graduate student
Tasha: 那我们就玩一些
Tasha: Let's play something like
Tasha: 飞花令
Tasha: the Flying Flower Game.
Lucia: 哦还可以
Lucia: Oh, that's possible.
Katrina:  我们开始扫了吗
Katrina: Are we starting to clean?
Jake: 对可以扫
Jake: Yes, you can start cleaning.
Jake: 是刚刚说什么研究生
Jake: What were you saying about graduate students?
Lucia: 飞花令
Lucia: The Flying Flower Game.
Katrina:  可以扫我房间
Katrina: Can I clean my room?
Jake:我去
Jake: I'm going.
Tasha: 你会玩吗
Tasha: Do you know how to play?
Jake: 害怕
Jake: Scared.
Katrina:  什么飞花令
Katrina: What's the Flying Flower Game?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Katrina:  明天的游戏吗
Katrina: Is it tomorrow's game?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 明天的游戏
Lucia: Tomorrow's game.
Jake: 对明天再再琢磨整点啥
Jake: Yes, we'll think about what else to do tomorrow.
Lucia: 用古诗词飞吗
Lucia: Using ancient poetry?
Lucia: 还是飞什么
Lucia: Or what to use?
Katrina:  古诗词我不行
Katrina: I'm not good at ancient poetry.
Tasha: 不然用什么飞
Tasha: Then what else to use?
Lucia: 哈哈这个这个
Lucia: Haha, this game
Lucia: 游戏不是
Lucia: isn't
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: just
Lucia: 已经扩展到各种各样的游戏领域了
Lucia: limited to one type of game anymore.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Katrina:  比如呢
Katrina: For example?
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: Can't think of an example.
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For example, it doesn't come out
Lucia: 因为你问住我了
Lucia: Because you stumped me
Tasha: 你说已经扩展到各个领域了
Tasha: You said it has expanded into various fields
Tasha: 我就想问问扩展到哪些领域了
Tasha: I just wanted to ask, which fields has it expanded into?
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 就是好像现在也没有原来那么传统
Lucia: It's like, it doesn't seem as traditional as before
Lucia: 就是比如说
Lucia: For example,
Lucia: 刚开始不是只有一
Lucia: At first, there was only one
Lucia: 比如说就是花字带花字的
Lucia: For example, with floral patterns
Lucia: 后来就变成什么什么意向的
Lucia: Later, it became something with some kind of intention
Lucia: 或者说描述啥啥的
Lucia: Or something descriptive
Tasha: 哦哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh, oh
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Alright
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 挺好一会呃
Jake: Great, in a bit, um
Jake: 一会就是我要扫房间
Jake: In a bit, I'll be sweeping the room
Jake: 然后你们可以
Jake: And you guys can
Jake: 我先扫楼上
Jake: I'll sweep upstairs first
Jake: 然后你们可以先下楼去讨论
Jake: Then you guys can go downstairs to discuss
Jake: 然后我扫楼下的时候你们再上来啊
Jake: And then when I sweep downstairs, you can come back up
Tasha: 啊就是不能有人是吧
Tasha: Ah, so no one can be there, right?
Jake:就是我的
Jake: Yeah, in the range of my phone, no one can be there
Jake: 手机的范围里面不能有人
Jake: In the range of my phone, no one can be there
Lucia: 扫之前跟我说一声
Lucia: Let me know before you sweep
Lucia: 因为我要把那边挂两件衣服拿出去
Lucia: Because I need to take out the clothes hanging there
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 那我要不然我还能挂着两件湿衣服很奇怪
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll be weird if I leave two wet clothes hanging there
Jake: 对对对那两件可能就哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, yeah, those two might just, hahaha
Jake: 这就相当于是
Jake: They'd become
Jake: 这个屋子里边固有的财产了
Jake: Like the fixed property of this room
Lucia: 哈哈哈就把它拿出来
Lucia: Hahaha, just take them out
Lucia: 然后就就就基本上只剩下箱子和包了
Lucia: Then basically, there'll only be boxes and bags left
Lucia: 别的我都塞进去了
Lucia: I've stuffed everything else in
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 成语接龙
Tasha: Idiom Solitaire
Lucia: 成语接龙现在可以
Lucia: We can play Idiom Solitaire now
Tasha: 你画我猜
Tasha: Pictionary
Lucia: 我是一个什么都可以的p人
Lucia: I'm a person who's okay with anything
Tasha: 我在说一些很传统的游戏
Tasha: I'm talking about some very traditional games
Lucia: 真心话大冒险
Lucia: Truth or Dare
Tasha: 摇骰子
Tasha: Roll the dice
Lucia: 摇骰子也可以
Lucia: Rolling the dice works too
Lucia: 那赢的人喝
Lucia: The winner drinks
Tasha: 输的人喝酒
Tasha: The loser drinks
Lucia: 赢的人喝输的人也喝
Lucia: The winner drinks, and the loser drinks too
Lucia: 没有奖惩机制啊
Lucia: There's no reward or punishment system here
Tasha: 我说输的人喝
Tasha: I said the loser drinks
Lucia: 我以为是奖励赢的人喝
Lucia: I thought the winner gets rewarded by drinking
Lucia: 惩罚输的人喝酒呢
Lucia: Punishing the loser by making them drink
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Tasha: 怎么啦
Tasha: What's up
Alice: 呵呵充电宝掉了
Alice: Haha my power bank fell
Tasha: 充电宝
Tasha: Power bank
Alice: 这我腰里别着呢
Alice: I had it clipped to my waist
Alice: 因为我没有兜
Alice: Because I don't have pockets
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 没事我扶着呢你可以粘一粘好
Lucia: It's okay, I'll hold it, you can fix it
Alice:你往上拎对
Alice: Lift it up, yes
Alice: 啊可以可以
Alice: Ah, yes, yes
Alice:让我那个松紧带估着他
Alice: Let me use the elastic band to hold it
Shure:  立定
Shure: Stand still
Alice: 我把裙子往下拽让他估着就行
Alice: I'll pull my skirt down, so it holds
Lucia: 哎别我捏着捏着充电宝给他捏
Lucia: Don't worry, I'll pinch the power bank and hold it
Lucia: 关机了
Lucia: It's off
Alice: 算了给他弄弄掉吧不要了断了
Alice: Forget it, just let it fall, it's fine
Lucia: 那我就先征用这个充电宝好了
Lucia: I'll just use this power bank for now then
Lucia: 我看一眼我那个还有多少电
Lucia: Let me check how much battery I have left
Tasha: 聪明
Tasha: Smart
Katrina:  通州攻略哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Tongzhou guide, hahaha
Shure:  然后一搜全是环球影城
Shure: Then you search and it's all Universal Studios
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter
Jake:就是一会的扫描活动都在吗
Jake: So, the scanning activity is happening soon, right?
Jake: OK一会的扫描活动就是我在下面扫
Jake: Okay, for the scanning activity, I'll be scanning below
Jake: 然后我下面扫完之后
Jake: After I'm done scanning below
Jake: 呃我会躲在一个房间里面
Jake: Uh, I'll hide in a room
Katrina:  然后我们去找你
Katrina: Then we go find you
Jake: 然后我为了不扫到人
Jake: And I do it to avoid scanning people
Jake: 所以说我会在里面待着
Jake: So I'll be staying inside.
Jake: 然后我让刘帅下来叫你们
Jake: Then I'll have Choiszt come down to call you guys.
Jake: 然后但是我不能扫到你们对吧
Jake: But I can't see you guys, right?
Jake: 嗯所以说你们也要躲在一个房间里面
Jake: Yeah, so you guys need to hide in a room too.
Jake: 就你们得躲在就你们就躲在
Jake: Just hide, just hide in...
Jake: 你们就在你们就室外吧
Jake: You guys just stay outside, okay?
Jake: 好吧好对
Jake: Alright, that's right.
Choiszt: 一楼扫完了他们不都去一楼都可以去一楼
Choiszt: After I finish sweeping the first floor, everyone can go to the first floor.
Jake: 就是我上楼的时候不能扫到人
Jake: The thing is, I can't see anyone when I go upstairs.
Jake: 我上楼的时候你们在
Jake: When I go upstairs, you guys should...
Jake: 对对对对嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Jake: 然后你们在这就聊一聊明天的安排吧
Jake: Then you guys can discuss tomorrow's plans here.
Choiszt: 反正我叫他们下去他们就下去藏好
Choiszt: Anyway, I'll call them down, and they'll hide.
Jake: 对你们就你们
Jake: Yeah, you guys just...
Jake: 就就就出门就好
Jake: Just go outside, it's fine.
Jake: 你们也可以
Jake: You guys can...
Jake: 现在在外边都都行
Jake: Stay outside now, it's all good.
Jake: 总之就是我不能扫到人
Jake: The main thing is, I can't see anyone.
Jake: 你们聊一聊啊
Jake: You guys chat.
Jake: 明天安排多多
Jake: Discuss tomorrow's plans a lot.
Jake: 多交流多交流
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Jake: 多交流
Jake: Talk more.
Jake: 反正明天大概是就是就是在户外
Jake: Anyway, tomorrow is basically outdoors.
Jake: 然后加点压花什么的对吧
Jake: And we'll add some pressed flowers, right?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Jake: 多说话啊多说话
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Shure:  多交流的方式是什么
Shure: How do we talk more?
Shure:  多喝酒就多
Shure: Drink more, and you'll talk more.
Shure:  交流了哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Lucia: 边喝边唠嗑啊
Lucia: Drink and chat at the same time.
Lucia: 那咱整两盅
Lucia: Let's have a couple of drinks.
Katrina: 浓密延长其实都差不多了
Katrina: Dense and extended, they're all about the same.
Katrina: 而且我估计你女朋友也不是很懂就截给你了
Katrina: And I guess your girlfriend doesn't really understand, so she just sent it to you.
Tasha: 你要喝尝尝这个吗
Tasha: Do you want to try this drink?
Shure:  其实就是
Shure: Actually...
Shure:  刚才把你的橙汁换成了葡萄汁
Shure: I just swapped your orange juice with grape juice.
Shure:  他基本就是只喝了一口而已
Shure: He basically just took one sip.
Lucia: 你不喝了吗
Lucia: Aren't you drinking anymore?
Tasha: 我不是你可以尝尝啊
Tasha: I'm not, but you can try it.
Tasha: 我刚术后一个月内不能喝酒
Tasha: I can't drink alcohol for a month after the surgery.
Tasha:但是 我没有忍住然后喝了一点
Tasha: But I couldn't resist and drank a little.
Tasha: 然后我慢慢喝就行
Tasha: So now I just drink slowly.
Lucia: 我喝一下你介意吗
Lucia: Do you mind if I drink?
Tasha: 不介意没事
Tasha: I don't mind, it's okay.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's fine.
Lucia: 那我就喝了
Lucia: Then I'll have a drink.
Lucia: 其实我也不介意但是有的会介意一般会先问一下
Lucia: Actually, I don't mind either, but some people do, so I usually ask first.
Lucia: 你这个屏幕好酷啊
Lucia: This screen is really cool.
Lucia: 是像素哎
Lucia: It's pixelated.
Tasha: 你看点他就会有羊然后你把羊给拖过来
Tasha: If you tap on it, there will be sheep, and you can drag the sheep over.
Lucia: 那这些羊如果你很长时间不管他他会消失吗
Lucia: If you ignore the sheep for a long time, will they disappear?
Tasha: 不会
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 那你不断的点岂不是就会有很多很多的羊
Lucia: So if you keep tapping, there will be lots and lots of sheep?
Tasha: 对然后可以跳到水里面
Tasha: Yeah, and you can make them jump into the water.
Lucia: 哦是以这样的方式减少羊的数量吗
Lucia: Oh, is that how you reduce the number of sheep?
Tasha: 投河一只
Tasha: Toss one into the river.
Choiszt: 然后那个沙发上的东西也收一下
Choiszt: And also tidy up the stuff on the sofa.
Shure:  他先什么
Shure: What did he do first?
Katrina: 他先把我拉黑的
Katrina: He blocked me first.
Katrina: 全平台拉黑
Katrina: Blocked me on all platforms.
Shure: 你先把他拉黑一遍
Shure: You should block him back first.
Katrina: 我加都不想加好吗
Katrina: I don't even want to add him, okay?
Katrina: 他当时考完研还给我发短信呢
Katrina: He even texted me after his exams.
Nicous:  他还有脸发短信
Nicous: He had the nerve to text you?
Shure:  嗯就是
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  然后当时我就是属于呃
Katrina: At that time, I just, um...
Katrina:  就是不想回也不想拉黑
Katrina: I didn't want to reply or block him.
Katrina:  哦也有可能跟版本有关
Katrina: Oh, it might be related to the version.
Katrina:  但是这个牌子是日本牌子呀
Katrina: But this brand is Japanese.
Katrina: 差别不大啦女生看不出来吧
Katrina: There's not much difference, girls can't tell.
Shure: 确实
Shure: True.
Katrina: 明天一天都在外面吗
Katrina: Are you going to be out all day tomorrow?
Katrina: 这还有佛教的东西
Katrina: There's some Buddhist stuff here.
Katrina: 我还要去雍和宫还个愿呢
Katrina: I still need to go to the Yonghe Temple to fulfill a vow.
Katrina: 我觉得特别准
Katrina: I think it's really accurate.
Shure: 我就应该去求财运
Shure: I should go there to pray for wealth.
Katrina: 当时我自己求的财运
Katrina: I prayed for wealth for myself.
Katrina: 给我两个好朋友求的考研上岸
Katrina: And for two of my good friends to pass their exams.
Katrina: 那两个都上岸了其他没上岸
Katrina: Both of them passed, others didn't.
Shure: 完了我给我妹求的学业
Shure: I just prayed for my sister's studies.
Katrina: 学业应该也还行
Katrina: Her studies should be fine too.
Nicous: 是在雍和宫里面买的
Nicous: It was bought inside Yonghe Temple.
Nicous: 380
Nicous: 380.
Katrina:  就是那个卖手串的集市是吧
Katrina: It's that market where they sell bracelets, right?
Tasha: 潘家园
Tasha: Panjiayuan.
Shure:  潘家园跟北新桥离多远呢
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Beixin Bridge?
Shure: 潘家园跟雍和宫离多远啊
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Yonghe Temple?
Katrina: 款式是一模一样的
Katrina: The style is exactly the same.
Katrina: 据说应该是有正版和盗版的区别的
Katrina: They say there's a difference between the original and the counterfeit.
Shure: 我需要充电了
Shure: I need to recharge.
Katrina: 哇明天又是大晴天
Katrina: Wow, tomorrow will be sunny again.
Katrina:  明天二十八度呢
Katrina: It'll be 28 degrees tomorrow.
Shure: 你滚啊
Shure: Get lost.
Katrina:  对就是睫毛打底是先
Katrina: Yeah, first use the eyelash primer.
Katrina: 用睫毛打底再用睫毛膏
Katrina: Use the primer and then the mascara.
Katrina: 她给你的意思就是睫毛打底她也要
Katrina: What she means is she also wants the eyelash primer.
Katrina: 睫毛膏就买刚刚的那KISSME的
Katrina: Just get the KISSME mascara we saw earlier.
Katrina:  这公园有那什么大摆锤什么的玩
Katrina: This park has that big swing ride and other stuff.
Nicous:  他一般写预售都是规定的是吧
Nicous: He usually specifies the presale conditions, right?
Katrina: 应该是可以当天发
Katrina: It should be shipped the same day.
Katrina: 因为他们基本上都是专柜采购的
Katrina: Because they usually source from official counters.
Katrina: 你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you guys coming tomorrow?
Katrina:  他说就明天户外
Katrina: He said just tomorrow outdoors.
Alice: 露西你见我的线了吗
Alice: Lucia, have you seen my thread?
Lucia: 呃在这里
Lucia: Uh, it's here.
Shure:  好困啊
Shure: So sleepy.
Katrina:  我想洗澡呀
Katrina: I want to take a shower.
Shure: 洗过了
Shure: Already did.
Katrina:  就去西海子公园吧
Katrina: Let's go to Xihai Park then.
Shure:  唱吧你就
Shure: Just sing, will you?
Katrina:  通利弗尼亚
Katrina: Tonglifonia.
Katrina:  我真笑死
Katrina: I'm literally dying of laughter.
Alice: 你的手串
Alice: Your bracelet.
Katrina:  还可以划船呢
Katrina: We can even go boating.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: So tired.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  哎北京好适合带富士相机
Katrina: Beijing is so perfect for a Fuji camera.
Shure:  是的我跟你讲
Shure: Totally, I'm telling you.
Tasha: 拍出来很好看
Tasha: It looks really good on camera.
Tasha: 好烦呀嗯
Tasha: So annoying, hmm.
Katrina:  这一两个地方差不多够了
Katrina: These one or two spots should be enough.
Katrina:  因为等我们出门估计又2点多然后
Katrina: Because by the time we leave, it'll probably be around 2 something.
Katrina:  这公园还挺漂亮
Katrina: This park is pretty nice.
Katrina:  OK就西海子公园
Katrina: Okay, let's go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  你就拉着人家唱你这个你你唱的歌吧
Shure: Just pull them over and sing your song, the one you sing.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  他们听过这歌吗
Shure: Have they heard this song before?